european space agency this is mission
control houston please call station for
a voice check
station this is issa how do you hear me
and isa dg we have you loud and clear
welcome to the international space
station
hello samantha and really great to hear
you
today we are very honored to have mrs
roberto mitzola the president of
european parliament with us on this call
the european commission president mrs
van der lion just gave a very important
speech on the state of the union and she
really outlined that we are under crisis
and europe has to act together
in order to really come out of this
crisis strong and space of course is one
vehicle is one element to get out of
this crisis stronger
in times of crisis you need innovation
and that is what we're offering here in
uh through space so i'm really looking
forward to this discussion of mrs
mitzola and i'm sure she has many many
questions and many topics to discuss
with you so welcome here
hello madam president it's uh it's such
an honor to welcome you here on board of
the international space station and
through you and
the european parliament as elected
representatives of all of europeans i
feel like today i have an opportunity to
welcome every european man woman and
child on the international space station
so thank you for this uh privilege and
this opportunity
well first of all hello samantha and
grand piace
los pacios
congratulations very much samantha on
becoming the first female european
commander of the international space
station and i love the flag that you are
standing in front of
thank you yes it's it's a privilege and
an honor to be able to display the
european flag here today and
this particular flag will fly back home
with me uh in in a few weeks when the
mission is over and so i will be very
honored if there will be an opportunity
to hand it over to you as a president of
the european parliament
well the honor would be all mine i would
very much like to meet with you in
person when you come back
uh but perhaps a little bit of questions
a lot of people will see this
conversation and i i really want to know
what what does it feel like to be
in your position today what are your
duties if i can think of so many young
people they dream on becoming you know
footballers famous actors musicians but
becoming an iss commander must be
mind-blowing so how did this happen when
did you think this would be possible and
how did you manage something so amazing
well i i think what what's truly amazing
is to be up here in space and and be
able to serve first and foremost as a
crew member of the international space
station and i
uh it was my dream since i was a small
child to one day be able to fly to space
i i was inspired by by many things i
think from you know marveling at the
beauty and mystery of the night sky to
amazing teachers from elementary school
on who really transmitted to me a
passion for for a discovery for
exploration for uh for adventure uh
books i read tv shows and then growing
up in school a passion for science
technology so i eventually became an
engineer by education and then i decided
to serve in in the italian military i
was trained as a combat pilot for a few
years
and then about 13 years ago i had this
amazing opportunity of
of joining isa as part of the european
astronaut corps and i had one first
mission a few years ago and on this
second mission i will have the privilege
for a short time to serve as commander
of the space station which which really
just means uh doing my best to enable
the um amazing team that we have here in
orbit to perform at their best
you know taking care of the well-being
of the team
ensure smooth communication with the
ground
and in case of of nominal situations or
emergencies making sure that i
coordinate it's a you know an efficient
and effective response on on behalf of
our team here on orbit but most
importantly really looking uh working uh
well together with the extended team
that we have all around the world uh
including our columbus control center in
europe in munich
well i can tell you that if i was a
young girl looking at you today i think
you would inspire me to at least dream
of
of
embarking on on this amazing path that
you
embarked on from a young girl if i can
say and until today that you are
at such an amazing place with such an
amazing example to give
to young girls around the world if we
can maybe a little bit more detail like
what is the most promising or exciting
project that you are currently
developing at the at the international
space station i know that there is a
variety of research projects including
on medicine materials physics or biology
undertaken on the iss perhaps you could
describe the ones that were most
exciting
or memorable to you
yes absolutely you're absolutely right
madame president we have the an amazing
laboratory up here in space where we
take advantage of this very unique
condition of microgravity which is
really weightlessness you know right
just like you know i'm floating here
everything floats we can
switch off the effects of of gravity as
long as we appear in space and so
there's a number of uh phenomena that
happen in but in life sciences in
biological systems you know we study our
own body we study animal models we study
plants cell tissues tissue culture cell
cultures
and also in the physical phenomena and
actually
i would be
you know it's always hard to say this is
my favorite experiment or this is the
most exciting one i don't want to do
that but maybe just the ones i've worked
on recently were mostly in the physical
domains one of the things we study up
here is the stability and behavior of
forms and emotions that is very
different in microgravity and allows us
to really get an understanding of the
physics involved there and that is
incredibly useful in in the
medicine industry food industry and in
general the the chemical
industry materials i think you mentioned
are also very important it's a you know
you you have an opportunity by switching
up gravity to get a deep understanding
of the physical phenomena involved for
example in metal um melts
but also i'm very fascinated by the
technological development iss is a
stepping stone to go further and and
continue to explore the solar system and
so it's also important to continue to
develop technologies and mature
technologies that um enable that um for
example just recently i had an
opportunity to work with the isa anita
ii which is a a very compact technology
to automatically analyze the composition
of the air to make sure that we do not
have for example any toxic substances in
the air well i think that that's that
sounds amazing and you know i'm standing
here actually i'm sitting here and no no
lack of gravity here i'm sitting very
much firmly in my chair uh in the
european parliament behind me is the
plenary so which is where all the
members of the european parliament
gather together
but we don't talk enough about space we
don't talk about enough about behavioral
aspects
i would like to see more members of the
european parliament that have a stem
educational background more women in
science
and technology
i i see that there's a big lack or a big
gap between what we as politicians do
and the decisions that we need to take
and the impact of such decisions on the
research on the discoveries that you
make but also on the awareness
of what
how our behavior here on earth should
change should be more educated should be
understood as having such an impact even
on your
on what you see so perhaps a question is
like what role can your activities i
mean here i would like advice that you
would give me and my colleagues for
example increasing our understanding of
space around the earth to help us
understand and tackle our most pressing
challenges like
like climate change you know it's a word
we use all the time
uh but we like to use it in a big in a
big format and not in how we can change
our life how our laws can can re can if
not reverse slow down the catastrophic
climate change we have seen and are
seeing on earth
yes absolutely i think that we uh we are
transitioning uh or probably that
transition has happened already to a
perception of space as something
separate like a separated domain
to something that just permeates our
societies our economies our industries
our ways of living together and our
ability to tackle big global challenges
from you know geopolitical crisis to a
climate change to food security
everything nowadays every solution is
enabled in general i would say probably
by technology and scientific
understanding but specifically by space
infrastructures
and so
making sure that we continue to develop
that infrastructure that we continue to
develop and improve the ability to
exploit that infrastructure to deliver
information data and services for the
benefits of all our citizens
and and making sure of course that we
can maintain that infrastructure safe
all of that i think has become uh
strategically important and so i
absolutely agree with you i think it's
very important for our leaders uh
elected officials decision makers to
have a deep understanding of the
potential of space
and you know now when i tell my children
tonight that i have spoken to you
i'm sure they're going to ask me this
question and i'm sure they're going to
want me to have asked you this so i'm
going to do it um and if you can explain
a little bit what your day looks like
you know what are your your day-to-day
challenges i could see while we were
preparing
this this conversation i could see you
trying to hold make sure the bottle of
water is held and not flying around
behind you
what are the biggest challenges you have
and then if you have free time
um
how do you spend it and how many people
do you interact with and do you do you
call home often how how is it i guess
technology has allowed this to become
easier than uh for members of the if of
the iss in previous years but but i
think still there are challenges i i if
you can just
lay it down to how i would explain it to
my to my children
yes absolutely so uh we have pretty busy
work days which starts around 7 30 in
the morning like in many offices we
start with a meeting
except that our meeting
occurs on space to ground radio and
it occurs
via satellite communication so that we
are able to talk for a few minutes with
all the control centers around the world
who are responsible for
the operations on the international
space station
and and then we all go off to our tasks
for the day like for example today i
have spent actually all of my morning
working on a experiment
most likely i will not be just working
on my own on that experiment i will be
talking to uh people on the ground who
are either the developer of the
experiments or in any way are experts on
that experiment so that can
guide me through it if there's any issue
we can troubleshoot uh together so
although we we look like we're very
isolated up here in space so we're
actually in very very close connection
with this
enormous extended team of researchers
and scientists and engineers and flight
controllers all over the world and so
the day then goes by pretty quickly
around 7 30 in the evening we have
another uh
one of those conferences of those
meetings uh on space to ground to wrap
up the day
we do have um throughout the day also
two and a half hours of
mandatory uh workouts like physical
activity
we have a machine that allows us to do
weight lifting and weightlessness which
i know sounds like an easy win but it's
actually a pretty intense workout
because the machine does create the
resistance we need to make sure we train
our muscles and also keep our bones
strong otherwise in space because of the
weightlessness we would
experience
some kind of very accelerated
osteoporosis which obviously we do not
want
and in terms of the free time yes
absolutely i call my my family on on
most days and uh as you hinted uh
technology really allows us to to feel
to feel connected and maintain that that
presence also in our in our family lives
well thanks for that it sounds like a
very busy day that you have every day
and that you can really need teamwork
also to be able to to to spread it out
towards uh one day i think we're we're
running sort of
shortly out of time but perhaps one
question that has that has been um put
uh to me uh and to ask you uh it's about
a debris in this space so while there
are about two thousand active satellites
orbiting the earth at the moment there
are also around three 000
dead ones
littering space
and there are also around 34 000 pieces
of space
junk bigger than 10 centimeters in size
and millions of smaller pieces that
could nonetheless let's say prove
disastrous if they hit something
are you working in any way on the issue
of space debris and have you experienced
yourself dangers that space that
proposed to the iss and all other
functioning satellites
yes well first of all i would like to
say this is a topic on which isa
works hard and intensively with the
space safety program and the space
debris office
here on iss yes we
come in contact quite frequently with uh
with the issue in fact just uh yesterday
the flight controllers on the ground
were tracking what we call a conjunction
which means a piece of space debris that
is big enough to be monitored from the
ground you know there's assets of
situational awareness where those pieces
of debris get tracked and if there is a
even a remote chance that that piece of
debris might come in contact with the
space station then the flight
controllers plan an avoidance maneuver
so we turn
and basically move out of the way
but the the quantity
the increasing quantity of space debris
in low earth orbit of course makes those
potential conjunctions a lot more
frequent than they used to be and it
also becomes more complicated to plan
those debris avoidance maneuvers because
you might move out of the way but you
also have to make sure that when you
move you don't get into another
potential conjunction so your your
degrees of freedom there become
more constraints so just to finish the
story that debris abundance
and so the conjunction cleared that
piece of debris in the end did not
pose a threat but it's certainly
something that comes up fairly often um
but yeah on but in terms of what we do
at the european space agency i would
actually uh love to hear what the
director general ashbach uh would like
to offer on this topic
no thanks uh
samantha in fact we are doing a lot as
uh as you say um the european parliament
in strasbourg is actually not too far
away from
our center we just opened a new space
safety center in darmstadt which is in
in germany
but really dealing with
space safety space traffic management
space debris issues which we are
experiencing so what we do is of course
monitoring the state but also telling
our satellites commanding our satellites
then to fly avoidance maneuvers in fact
we're doing this now much more often
than we used to do in the past uh today
we do it about once a week every 10 days
we used to do it every couple of months
so this also shows how much debris there
is uh just the most recent uh asa test
which happened at the end of last year
or caused a huge amount of debris where
matthias mara our astronaut had to take
shelter in the in the capsule and the
space station had to fly these orbit uh
maneuvers to avoid it so yes this is a
huge issue uh and also uh then we need
regulation we need international
regulation but also we need technology
where we can address the issues for
example we develop a new uh satellite
that literally grabs an upper stage of a
rocket and takes it out of the orbit in
order to just get rid of one piece it's
a bit like a vacuum cleaner or garbage
collection if you wish in space and this
is something that
that we're really developing but of
course in a large scale and this really
reminds us that um out there in space we
are of course depending on each other
it's not only europe that has to take
care of its asset it's really a global
effort and there we have international
mechanisms that do that united nations
and and other bodies so yes sir this is
a big task and we are quite active
actually at the european level we have a
so-called zero debris policy which uh i
am uh installing now with my member
states where we would like to have just
like on on ground where we have carbon
neutrality uh we would like to have uh
space debris neutrality by 2030 up in
space that means one object in means an
object out and this is of course a big
task and uh we are leaders in europe
thank you so much such an honor such an
honor madam president the honor
[Music]
this is houston acr that concludes the
event
thank you to our participants from esa
station we're now resuming operational
audio communications